well he's not my husband yeah gwen
stefani and blake shelton
aren't married just yet and on monday's
episode of jimmy kimmel live
she politely corrected guest host dua
lipa when she
accidentally referred to blake as her
hubby
so i heard that you've been spending
quarantine with your husband blake
shelton at the
ranch in oklahoma who else was with you
how was that
um well he's not my husband but that
sounded
cool when you said it no oopsie
but totally cute right anyway
gwen opened up about life in quarantine
on blake's oklahoma ranch
with her brother her three sons and
blake's family
every day was like a new thing like a
baby armadillo today or we got baby wild
hog
like we got milk we were like and
everything turned into like
getting to try to like learn how to cook
sourdough bread like everybody else in
the world like we just have a lot of fun
baby armadillos and sourdough random but
i don't hate it any time i can be around
blake is is
you know a blessing clearly the couple
is all about quality time
but gwen admits she has one habit that
blake could
definitely do without if i'm being
serious probably like being on my phone
he doesn't like that probably probably
but he likes me a lot so
i'd love to do no wrong and while blake
and gwen have been together since
2015 a source told et in june that they
aren't
focused on tying the knot just yet
adding that the 50 year old
just a girl singer is in no hurry to
walk down the aisle
blake saved my life everybody knows that
like we are just
having the time of our lives and we
never expected that this late in our
lives so
we're just trying to save her every
every moment together quote gwen and
blake
trust and love each other and have truly
built a wonderful family together
so right now she feels like she doesn't
need to rock the boat
i love being with him back in 2019 blake
told et
how they would reveal a potential
engagement if
that were to happen i promise you we
won't break the news
in any of the grocery store trash
magazines
when it happens you'll hear about it and
naturally he couldn't help but
swoon hard for his leading lady
she's never not been supportive or a
cheerleader or just
just the most encouraging person i've
ever had in my life
on any level it's unbelievable
how supportive she is